moi je suis plus prudent je regarde un
peu la réalité des choses la réalité de
josé du corps électoral
je considère que nous partons de rien
les grands marche puisque nous n'avons
pas aujourd'hui d'élus municipaux
régionaux départementaux qui sont en
marche
donc il faudra pour ce faire une
opposition mobilisée
un certain nombre de républicains qui
acceptent soutiennent la démarche du
chef de l'état du gouvernement
gros travail mais il n'est pas sans
espoir
donc moi ce que je souhaite avec vos
propres marche au sénat s'est plainte
d'avoir le maximum possible je n'ai pas
fait de chiffres d'échelle et si nous
doublons le groupe s'est déjà bien tard
bordeaux